nella roma allora ragazzi ci siamo e
siamo quasi al 2 centesimi e bisogno di
happy meal per me è un'emozione unica
anche perché non è tutto il xix
rimorchio quindi come avevo detto
ragazzi gli episodi prima del
duecentesimo compreso il duecentesimo
saranno specialissimi a partire anche
giada quello di oggi che un qualcosa di
diverso rispetto al solito il prossimo
sarà uno speciale wow
ecco il duecentesimo sarà una roba
incredibile ma ci arriveremo
volevo provare perché in 200 episodi
quasi non ho ancora fatto è più il so
mobile perché l'hanno fatto anche sono
paesi ormai da un sacco di tempo è
arrivato il momento speriamo che non
faccia schifo anche se dal menu promette
bene vai play 1a perché non credo sia
online perché ci sono i livelli già
fatti ma va bene ma ho capito come si
gioca
l'ho fatto io un altro boccadamo avanti
dunque con tutorial anti sticazzi
facciamo il 15o questo questo è un
livello fatto che hanno cambiato gli
sfondi raga circa fatta non mi fa
stranissimo non era semplice però ci si
può provare a nyon credo sarà un livello
sono morto parecchio difficile visto e
considerato una donna molto benissimo
ragazzi ha fatto meglio di quello
normale
ok che non sono i livelli dell'online
quindi non è che non c'è gente stupida
che fa livelli ma porca [ __ ] e fatto
cioè si sono studiati mi ha [ __ ] 2
euro cioè praticamente ragazzi sono
tutti degli impossible livelli sono solo
fatti non come imposti norma livelli
lunghi vai avanti
ok adesso riprenditi riprendimi
bravissimo però vai veloce perfetto e
fin qua
ok a minchia lo seguì la freccia pure
e morto servivo sono vivo ci sono ci
sono non sono vivo però mi sono preso
deve fare tutto a posto
in poche parole ragazzi hanno
trasformato dai più in uno di quei
giochi che fai sul telefono dove fare un
livello è impossibile nonchè prime sia
facile di solito però hanno fatto
strettamente questa cosa può che siamo
stanchi di baires praticamente perfetto
ce l'ho fatta sono fortissimo ci ha
creduto come esito la mia mamma o dio
qua devo stare minchia spetta devo
seguire staffa renault madonna come ho
fatto io giuro non saprei neanche
spiegare che cacchio fatto che quando
seguire sta roba
mi sono fidato del due volte ma andata
di culo regalo che mi sono fidato di me
stesso cosa che non dovrei mai fare
soprattutto è primis perfetto
mica tre su tre temi uscito a farli
subito
ecco meno male che ho detto ragazzi è
difficilissimo fare anche un solo
livello viggiù dai crediamo l'ultima
volta questo vediamo dove vado a fine va
a fan culo ai ragazzi però proviamo n'è
un altro con tanto poi cambiare la
madonna il turbo non ho ben capito come
faccio a spingermi in avanti ma ok
difficilissimo di si è rotta la sedia
rotelle ma chi se ne frega vamonos se
sei controllare bene l'anno chuck non
così te la vuoi giocare col naso perché
razzo ti permette di muoversi in modi
molto strani sono diventato sì però devi
andare in avanti zio in avanti chi di
maneggiare madonna quanto lento ragazzi
facciamo a fare un livello cioè devo
fare anche anche solo il primo il primo
c'è chi giura incredibile 1 un livello 1
livello 1 ma si dividono in base ai
personaggi non ho capito sta cosa
ok allora tutto chiaro ma facciamo il
livello 7 che secondo me di difficoltà e
intermedia
dinho gia mica ve ne sono così tanti
livelli per ogni persona non è
impossibile
praticamente ci mettono gli altri fino
al 3 centesimo episodio talmente
difficile che prima che definiscono ci
metto 60 anni è fatto veramente bene
raganato ok ok ok ok ok non solo deve
andare di milito ho capito aspetta chi è
bravissimo ok tutto a posto radio tra
posto centra libro non troppo perché se
9 contro le spine ma bravo cazzo
cosa facciamo davanti va davanti a
davanti avanti pianissimo ok giro della
morte
no vabbè nuovo peso visto regala
spettacolo ho perso una gamba
chissenefrega tanto per il tesoro non è
vero non è vero non vado avanti sono
stupido va bene potete mettere i
checkpoint porca vacca e vai vai vai vai
zio piano minchia questo questo secondo
me non c'arriva ragazzi è molto più
riusciti quello che sembra pittura
ve l'ho detto era veramente difficile
richiede di atterrare in piedi perché
sono fuori dispiace la testa è veramente
di pc o ragazzi un livello ce la farò a
farlo appena ce la faccio per me sono
contento ma devo farcela non possa
essere un pluriventennale giocatore di e
business senza finire colombaia senza
nome ridicolo
sarebbe ridicolo e io non l'ho cui ok
molto bene prefetto minchia brumotti
dove vado alla destra di riprendere un
attimo la pendenza qua brevi la fed
bravo ancora pendenza perfetto
meraviglioso perfetto di fare la stessa
cosa ma dove cazzo vai dove minchia stai
andando spiegami chiuso un giorno quelli
che l'hanno fatto la versione mobile
hanno dovuto testare ogni livello perché
sono stati pazzi sono diventati matti
non si capisce un cazzo che è stato
fatto bene perfetto
giovanna popolare devo harmony finito ho
finito cioè al traguardo non è vero
questo passo io che cup successo ci
proviamo ragazzi l'ultima volta questa
proprio l'ultimo tentativo vi faccio
vedere come va in diretta
così senza bavagli cose brano
gianluca bravo
andiamo avanti torniamo indietro ancora
facciamo quello che facciamo no col
veramente ne hai solo tre steve ok
adesso adesso mi abbasso abbasso ok ok
saltino saltino santino ok perfetto
perfetto perfetto perfetto e adesso dove
vado cosa faccio aiuto non so niente
hanno aspettato nodari sopra si apre con
cosolini a noi è già aperto che pirlo è
però come fa ma poca p lo capisci che
non ci sono i tag
e difficilissimo schiacciare i tasti
mentre c'è e infattibile sa che cosa c'è
lì che vorrei roteare ma non posso mio
dio
aspetta aspetta forse ci siamo perché
piano piano piano piano piano che quando
ci arriveremo pezzi da questo momento
epocale registrate registrati nostro già
registrando io che niente aspetta
aspetta aspetta aspetta aspetta non è
vero non è vero
dai vorrei che evocarlo ok
[Musica]
dio mio che il gioco impossibile
impossibile allora vedo solo una volta
più che il padre gli yuck ne faccio uno
a caso e poi concluso qua ragazzi però
io allora ha battuto se il bisogno sarà
speciale 199 sarà uno speciale e il 200
sarà un altro speciale dopo e 200 quindi
da 201 quando riprendo con gli episodi
normali riprendo con ottimismo ai
ragazzi perché stanno facendo cose
bellissime che mi piace un sacco per
quanto sia difficile e quindi voglio
giocarlo per bene e lo riprenderò
ragazzi quindi tranquilli ci saranno
altri episodi su questo per i limiti e
fatto proprio bene
e difficilissimo mai fatto bene quindi
se riuscissi a finire anche se livello
mentre parlo non sarebbe male
sarebbe veramente figo anzi sarebbe
molto figo perché non mi fai vincere con
free valor cosa cosa ti costa da gioco
del cazzo
fammi finire questo che ha paura se
mischiato casino dammi un traguardo ti
prego uno qualsiasi non me lo dai
e vabbè con lo slow motion
oddio lo slow motion perché dovevo
passarlo a veri problemi cerruti all ok
ce la facciamo ce la facciamo la
facciamo ci affacciamo ce l'ho fatta
fortissimo o mio dio mio dio si si si si
ho finito con una schiena un po strana
secondo me non è normale prova beh
signori questa è più il mobile
bellissimo bellissimo difficile ma
bellissimo penso che la difficoltà dei
livelli vado a scalare ovviamente se
parti all'inizio sono più facili io mi
sono buttato subito su quelli difficili
ma perché pensavo essendo giocatore di è
più vista prima che avete capito pensavo
di riuscire però effettivamente questo è
fatto un po diverso questo è fatto solo
per morire solo è fatto per farti
lanciare il hanno un contratto con la
apple to praticamente giochi un questo
gioco poi spacchi il telefono perché ti
incazzi vai dalla apple ne compri uno
nuovo e quindi vengono pagati per questo
però avviene sia piaciuto ragazzi cosa
mi piace anche vari social che come
detto descrizione senza stato chi siete
e noi ci vediamo come sempre al prossimo
vinto dai ragazzi
[Musica]